[Musik]
mit
hallo herzlich willkommen heiße kiste
cutter und zwar ist das ein rhetorisches
fladenbrot dekorieren ist die
küstenregion in norditalien und ich muss
sagen dass fladenbrot erinnert auch ein
bisschen und türkische fladenbrot was
ich gerne mit sesam und schwarzkümmel es
in die bütt laden profi wird auch vor
dem backen mit olivenöl bestrichen und
dann mit mehrfach und mit kräutern der
wahl bestreut
ich habe jetzt einmal ein basic rezept
für euch und zwar hier als lokaler meter
rosmarin und meersalz und dann noch eine
etwas aufgetürmte version mit zucchini
und oregano habe ich da noch mit drauf
und im prinzip könnt ihr das ganze
abwandeln wie er möchte
ich bereite das ganz gerne auch zu fuß
denn ich kann super gut vorbereiten kann
die brote aufgehen lassen und dann
einfach während wickeln das ganze
entweder im backofen backen oder vor
einem kugelgrill zum beispiel direkt
auch von einem coolen grill stein backen
also da können sie einfach selbst
entscheiden ich sage ich jetzt einfach
mal die zutaten für den hefeteig und
angeblich los für den hefeteig brauche
ich einen rüssel häfler 500 milliliter
lauwarmes wasser 3 ist sonys 1300 gramm
mehl und 100 milliliter olivenöl starten
wir mit un-hilfe zeigt dafür nehme ich
jetzt die hilfe und tat was sie in eine
große schüssel
da kommt jetzt das wasser mit ärztlich
ist kurz mit dem schneebesen
und gibt auch gleich den honig mit rein
der gibt den schülern dann muss ich dich
tollen geschmack und da zeigt auch so
ähnlich wie mein allererstes paket
rezept und es gelingt auch echt enorm
superlecker kommt noch die übrigen flut
haben mit ryan o'neal und natürlich auch
das öl und jetzt weder zeigt in etwa
fünf bis sieben minuten vor einem
schönen glatten und geschmeidigen teig
[Musik]
jetzt bereits fertig und schön
geschmeidig und jetzt nehme ich ihnen
hier heraus und fette meine arbeit heute
angekommen und das wird ein richtig
schöner weiter teilt mit der zeit
einfach ein bisschen zusammen formen zu
einer kugel jetzt fertig auch die
schütte und da kommt derzeit wieder
hinein wird auch mitfährt abgespeckter
kündet olivenöl oder in fast ganz berlin
auf einfacher geht einfach so wieder
nicht austrocknet und so lasst den zeigt
jetzt abgedeckt für eine stunde gehen
damit noch einfach schön locker wird
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig richtig gut
aufgegangen und jetzt hier die
arbeitsfläche bereits zum 1 da kommt
derzeit drauf den zeitlich gibt in vier
portionen 1
[Musik]
jetzt brauche ich daraus ovale
teigfladen auf die größe etwa und jetzt
setzt sich den pikes laden kaufmann
backblech wenig später das gelochte
blech tabaks einfach viel schöner und
gleichmäßiger durch und ich setze jetzt
auch nur 2 1 gleich weil ich einfach
nochmal aufgehen
[Musik]
er streift gezeigt werden und wissen mit
öl damit wird beim erneuten aufgehen
nicht austrocknen so lasse ich sie jetzt
abgedeckt an einem warmen ort für 30
minuten ruhen jetzt für die teigfladen
schön aufgegangen und jetzt kann ich mit
meinen fingern der kleine wellen
reinmachen geht man auch vom fladenbrot
bestreite ich die flammen noch mal mit
olivenöl und die klassischen für katze
bestreitet mit grobem meersalz und geht
noch rosmarin obendrauf zusätzlichen
könnte das ist jetzt meine klassische
variante stelle ich ganz kurz zur seite
und zeigt euch jetzt noch eine
alternative
und zwar arbeite ich jetzt noch vor
kratzern machen mit zucchini das heißt
die vorkasse könnt ihr auch gerne
reichlich belegen bei unserem italiener
gibt's nie wirklich in zahlreichen
variationen mit tomate mit schafkäse mit
ganz vielen anderen mit fisch kenne ich
die auch oder mit oliven oben drauf und
ich werde es noch mit zucchini machen
mit der zweiten hälfte
[Musik]
für die zickige version habe ich jetzt
hier schon so clinique eingehoben und
ganz dünne scheiben und die lege ich
jetzt hier antworten fächer art strüber
bestreut die auch mit meersalz und dann
mit getrockneten oregano oder passt
wirklich ganz gut
und wer möchte kann hier zum beispiel
ein bisschen schafskäse noch darüber
geben aber ich möchte einfach den vollen
geschmack dass fini mit dem oregano
hatten und wo werden die verkäufer jetzt
im vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 25 grad
ober unterhitze 15 minuten backen
[Musik]
die brote sind jetzt gebacken ich hab
jetzt kurz abkühlen lassen aber
normalerweise esse ich sie am liebsten
einfach ganz frisch ist hier auch hier
fehlt schon eine kleine hälfte oder ein
kleines stückchen und die könnt ihr euch
jetzt abbrechen und zum beispiel auch
als vorspeise genießen das heißt das
ganze investiert olivenöl brauchen
deshalb trüber und dann abweisen
mach ich jetzt nicht denn sonst wegen
mir gleich die kräuter wieder zwischen
den zähnen oder ihr könnt das brot auch
ein bisschen kleiner zu bereiten und
dann aufschneiden und filmen also je
nach zutaten nach wahl ist es wirklich
super soft und sehr weich und ich bin
wirklich mega lecker weiteres rezept
nach machen wollt und auch gerne mal
diese foto ausprobieren wollt geht auf
meinem blog auffällig news blog de da
steht noch mal die zutaten vielleicht
habt ihr auch schon eine eigene
abwandlungen und könnt dann davon
berichten
ich werde auf jeden fall bestimmt mal
wieder eine andere art und weise
zubereiten das heißt irgendwie in eine
andere richtung wenn wir die terraner
mit getrockneten tomaten zum beispiel
wir sind hier wird drauf alles was gut
schmeckt und ich wünsche euch jetzt
schon mal ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal bis
dann wird kann ich jetzt muss ich nicht
mehr reden
[Musik]
wenn